instead of grinding the thousands and
thousands and thousands of hours that i
did streaming and
i'm going to break everything down for
you guys in the next 30 days let's go oh
my goodness the precision the aim the
accuracy baby
i am tyler blevins you may know me as
ninja this class is about building and
establishing a streaming presence
whether you are a gamer or a non-gamer
let's go baby
i have cracked the code truly on how to
build a community engage with your
audience and make you the best possible
streamer that you can be you're going to
learn to set up and launch your stream
develop a style build a brand and make
your stream as professional as possible
hey everyone welcome to my youtube
channel you'll be learning alongside
people from all over the world and
you're going to be able to share your
streams and this journey alongside the
community of masterclass
when you're starting out try to have the
viewer list open at all times so that if
you see a brand new person come in you
can just say hey welcome to the stream
thank you so much for stopping in and
that might encourage that person to talk
to you and actually engage in the chat
and you might have earned your first
follower for life the two months in a
row welcome back man busan what's up man
how you doing what do i love most about
streaming it's so much fun you can bring
so much joy to other people and of
course obviously if you do everything
right it can be very lucrative as well
i started out in my mom's basement
streaming working at a fast food
restaurant going to college
and then i broke the record for the most
viewers in a stream the most
subscriptions the fastest growing
youtube channel in the world but if you
get some subs out here we are making
money
streaming is a place where you can just
express yourself this is my life i
absolutely love it and i'm happy to
share everything that i've learned if i
can do this anyone can do this
i'm ninja and this is masterclass
[Music]
[Music]
you